- Depuis deux mois, le mot
est sur toutes les lèvres.
- The variant Omicron...
- Omicron...
- Le variant Omicron...
- Le variant s'est répandu
sur la planète comme
une traînée de poudre.
- Omicron is probably
in most countries.
- Les cas sont plus nombreux
que jamais. Les systèmes
de santé craquent.
- La situation, dans
les prochaines semaines,
elle va être critique.
- Les incertitudes sont
nombreuses. Mais que sait-on
vraiment sur Omicron?
26 novembre 2021.
La propagation du virus en
Afrique du Sud et au Botswana
attire l'attention de l'OMS.
- So today, we are announcing
B.1.1.529 is a variant
of concern named Omicron.
- Un nouveau variant circule.
Et sa séquence génétique
n'a rien de rassurant.
Omicron comporte une
cinquantaine de mutations
par rapport au virus original.
Un nombre anormalement élevé.
Le variant Delta, par exemple,
en compte une quinzaine.
Les experts s'inquiètent
surtout de l'emplacement
de ces mutations.
La majorité d'entre elles
se situent sur le spicule, une
protéine à la surface du virus.
Le spicule permet au virus
de s'accrocher aux cellules
et de les infecter.
Des mutations sur le spicule
aident le virus à déjouer
en partie le système
immunitaire, même chez
les personnes vaccinées.
Par ailleurs, Omicron se répand
bien plus vite que le virus
original et ses autres variants.
Au Québec, il représente 20 %
des cas de COVID-19
le 12 décembre, et ce taux
grimpe à 80 % moins
d'une semaine plus tard.
En revanche, les données
actuelles suggèrent que
le variant Omicron cause
des infections moins sévères,
car il infecte les cellules
différemment.
Les coronavirus entrent
chez l'humain par le nez
et la bouche. En se multipliant,
ils descendent le long des voies
respiratoires.
S'ils se développent dans
les poumons et atteignent
d'autres organes vitaux,
des complications graves
peuvent survenir.
Omicron a toutefois changé
de stratégie. Plusieurs études
préliminaires remarquent que
ce variant peine à infecter
les poumons. Il se développerait
surtout dans le haut
du système respiratoire.
Cela contribuerait à expliquer
plusieurs phénomènes.
Plus concentré dans le nez
et la gorge, le virus fait
moins de dommages et se transmet
plus facilement.
À ce jour, on ne sait pas
à quel point la vaccination
freine cette transmission.
Mais une chose est sûre :
les vaccins aident le corps
à se défendre contre Omicron
une fois infecté.
Ils rendent les formes graves
de COVID-19 moins fréquentes.
Selon une étude britannique,
les risques d'hospitalisation
seraient réduits
de 65 % après deux doses
et 81 % après trois doses.
La vaccination permet donc
de désengorger les hôpitaux,
mais aussi de prévenir
l'apparition de nouveaux
variants. Car le virus mute plus
difficilement dans un organisme
en mesure de le combattre.
Aussi, selon une étude
sud-africaine, les personnes qui
ont été infectées par Omicron
posséderaient les anticorps
nécessaires pour contrer
la souche Delta.
La vague Omicron pourrait
alors freiner des variants
plus agressifs et contribuer
à développer une certaine
immunité dans la population.
Les chances de voir la COVID-19
éventuellement disparaître
sont minces. Mais la pandémie ne
sera pas éternelle pour autant.
Si la transmission diminue
et se stabilise sur une assez
longue durée, la maladie
sera déclarée endémique, au même
titre que le rhume et la grippe.
- To end the acute stage of the
pandemic, vaccines need to be
shared fairly and quickly with
all countries of the world.
- Au cours des prochains mois,
l'accès mondial au vaccin
sera un enjeu de taille.
Il jouera un rôle clé pour mieux
contrôler l'évolution du virus.
Plus de trois milliard de
personnes n'ont pas reçu
leur première dose.
Plusieurs facteurs seront aussi
à surveiller, comme les quatre
autres variants existants,
classés préoccupants,
et l'arrivée de médicaments
pour traiter la COVID-19.
Pour l'instant, la suite des
choses est difficile à prévoir,
car le virus est passé maître
dans l'art de déjouer les
pronostics. Mais nous apprenons
de semaine en semaine
à mieux le connaître.